what's up brother joseph how are you
doing i've been having some
really really reoccurring annoying
dreams regarding
myself and my mother-in-law okay um
more of an intimate personal
relationship
kind of dream you know yeah awkward
makes it awkward
you know i can i'm not going to imagine
it but i'll take your word for it how
about that
yeah yes that works um
it's gotten so like frequent
that the point that like even when i'm
trying
to like you know not be there mentally
in
when i'm awake and around my family and
it's just frustrating because it's like
i've talked with my wife about it she's
cool because it's like
it's a dream it's not like you're doing
anything so hey hold on
all things just stopped every digital
like zero and one just stopped turning
just now
you told your wife about this how'd that
go
it was awkward but my once i had the
kind of relationship
hey listen that may be the
understatement of planet earth
like i i mean it was awkward
yeah no i know this is nothing that's
awkward for me
because like
her mom is one of those people that like
her friends in high school would make
comments to her about her mom so it's
like
she's beautiful she has grown up yes
okay and so
your your wife has had to deal with this
forever right yes
okay and i wasn't weird when i said
anything to my wife about it like she
completely understood she's like you're
not the first guy to
have a dream and it just so happens to
be like about my mom
hey hold on like you're being for real
that's a real conversation you all had
yeah and she was just like cool man she
was like hey
it's it's just a dream you can't control
what you dream about as frustrating as
it is
as real as it is it's not real but like
listen i don't know what you've been i
don't know what you did in another life
but you married so well every day of
your life you should get down on both
knees and just be like
thanks man yep and she
like my wife is an angel on earth and
she's
yeah 37 weeks pregnant and she's 37
weeks pregnant
yes sir wow okay so
um man we're not even talking about the
dream i just can't even believe
one you're brave and you're like one of
the core principles of the show man is
that secrets destroy relationships and
right when you told me that i thought oh
my gosh man just the
tension that would be in your home you
had enough courage to say that
and you may have had enough courage to
say that because
um sounds like your wife is a just a
really remarkable human being
so um when you say recurring they're
happening how often are these dreams
happening
probably once every other week okay and
how often
are you in proximity to your
mother-in-law
pretty frequent like we go to the same
church we have dinner with them at least
once a week like
we're very close to my wife's parents
okay
and so it keeps happening
and you're now starting to feel awkward
in
the real world yeah because like i'm
i'm about to be a dad to a daughter and
i am just like
it's awkward for my own mental space
because my brain is just like
yo okay remember that dream that
happened last night and i'm like i would
really like to not think about that over
thanksgiving dinner
right now thank you yep
everyone in the united states just
nodded their head and they were like
yeah i could pretty much see that
yeah we're all with you on this one
joseph all right
perfect so is this dream a replay
is it essentially the same um
narrative every time is it different
don't get gratuitous man i i don't want
that stuff in my mind
but walk me through
different scenarios same end result okay
all right
so here's the thing good for you
and your wife sex dreams are almost
never about sex they are
intimate dreams are almost never about
intimacy they're about
i mean they can be about a million
different things but they're often about
being accepted
being deemed worthy being deemed up to
you know
that you've got a valued place here
and so what is your relationship like
with your mother-in-law
fantastic okay like she has
said she's made comments to my life that
she thinks of me like her own kid
um we're very close and like she talks
to me and my wife a lot about stuff
going on in her own personal life and
not
nothing like too in detail just like
she talks with us and we have open
conversations and it's
yeah so there's no hierarchy there's no
rule you're not walking around
feeling like uh i'm not i didn't i
didn't
she's disappointed in who you her
daughter married
everybody's rocking and rolling and
feeling great about life
yeah okay so here's two things one
i'm not a psychologist and psychologists
spend time
interpreting dreams and most people will
tell you dream interpretation
is voodoo right it's got some reality
but usually it's the reality is what how
it makes you feel so that's my question
to you
are you carrying shame around about this
are you annoyed by it are you frustrated
about it
um do you like it like what's going on
in your heart in your head here
d all of the above okay that's
the best way that i can answer that um
like everything that i love about my
wife it's she got from her mom
okay um but she's not your mom
no no she's not her mom yeah that's what
i meant yeah
yeah i i get that and it's like
it's just unfortunate that like the
person that i am married to
has all these great qualities that her
mom also has and it's just like
it's not unfortunate yeah i was like say
why is that a fortune it sounds awesome
hold on it is fantastic because they're
great people it's just
i don't want that image of my
mother-in-law
you know okay so do you want to
stop that dream yes
okay so i'm gonna i know
one thing that is from the the nightmare
research
it's from dr joyner and he's an
extraordinary researcher suicide
researcher
but um he walks through
a really a clear step-by-step path on
how to deal with nightmares and this
isn't a nightmare this may not work this
is the best i've got and what i would
tell you is
in short order if this doesn't work you
need to go see somebody
um a psychologist probably not a
therapist probably a psychologist
who is going to walk you through
other things about this dream here's the
challenge for you
as i think you like having this dream
you don't like what it means for you in
the real world is that fair
yeah that's fair and as long as you like
having the dream
man it's gonna recur and it's gonna
occur especially there's no power
dynamic
you're gonna have to make a decision
that i don't want this in my head
anymore
okay i honestly i don't think you're
there yet
i think you're more freaked out by it's
kind of weird and
it's not super common you're probably
going to call your buddies and be like
dudes guess what you're not going to do
that
and right so it's more you feel like a
freak
but you like it and until you decide i
don't want this
man it's going to keep looping back on
you but here's here's the rundown
okay um
you have to rescript this as the way dr
joyner calls it he had to rescript this
in writing okay so you have to write out
the scenario
and then you have to write out an
alternative ending
so let's say you are um
i don't know you come home to your house
and your mother-in-law's there and
there's nobody else
there and every time you have this dream
it always ends with a certain outcome
right you're going to rescript this
you're going to see that your
mother-in-law's there
you're going to choose to get back in
your car and you're going to leave
and then you're going to go somewhere
else and then when you get home your
mother-in-law's not going gonna be there
anymore she's not she's gonna quit
showing up
and then throughout the day after you
have written this down
you have to run this narrative through
your head multiple times you have to
practice it on a regular basis
okay he would say you have to retell the
new version of the dream throughout the
day
okay and what it does
it it resets your mind it it it creates
a new path for this dream to head down
once that ball gets pushed down the hill
does that make sense yeah
tell me if i'm crazy i don't think
you're gonna do that
like do the writing things out
it sounds fantastic and i would love to
not have this dream anymore
i really would really yeah
okay i mean i get hey i'm fundamentally
a guy and it's like
i know biologically great whoopty do but
like
mentally and where i want to be with my
wife
like because we want to be pastors and
like i don't want any
crap holding me down you know yes i do
um my guess is there's other things here
that we can't handle on a show
have you been to counseling recently no
why do you laugh at that no it
i sorry we're working through uh dave
ramsey's baby steps right now and it's
not in the budget for counseling and
stuff so here's what also is not in the
budget divorce
here's what also is not in the budget an
absolute
train wreck
between your mother-in-law and you and a
new baby girl
and all of the derivative mess that's
gonna happen
okay you don't have money not to do this
but my guess is you've got stuff in
there that you got to talk
to talk about is that fair or am i crazy
no that's
probably fair okay so here's the thing
you have a more connected relationship
than probably anyone i've ever heard of
you're the first person i i have ever
heard that
in my life that would have told their
wife what kind of dreams you're having
okay so i wanna high five to you and
high five to your wife
awesome awesome awesome that's a great
foundation to start from
i also think you've got some demons in
there you've got some conversations you
need to have with yourself with your
past with your
with your legacy with your heritage
there
it's worth going to spend some time with
a counselor okay especially if you're
going to take on a job where your job is
to care for other people
the third thing is man i want you to try
this i want you to sit down tonight
by yourself you're not going to show
this to anybody
i want you to rewrite this script
rewrite it
and then for the next week i want you to
fold this piece of paper up put in your
pocket and go through it a few times a
day
i show up at my house i walk in my
mother-in-law's there
i say hey i'll see you later you turn
around get back in your car and you
drive away
and then a couple hours later pull that
piece of paper out when you think about
it
read through this script make a mental
picture if you walk in the house you
trying to walk away
and do that several times do that
several times do that several times and
then
when you have if the dream goes away
great dr joyner's the smartest guy ever
and um you're healed and i'm gonna i'm
probably gonna just
start a dream show after that if not
um then you're right back where you
started you don't lose anything right
um and then you can have something else
to talk about with your counselor
but man that's a big deal it's a
it's a big deal and here's the thing you
said it best at the beginning and i want
to make sure everybody hears this
number one when it comes to dreams don't
ever feel
embarrassed or secretive or weird maybe
in this case
right i was going to say never have
secrets i mean
if you're dreaming about your
mother-in-law or your father-in-law
maybe hang on to that one yourself
maybe you don't bring that home and just
be like hey everybody um
i would probably say in my house i'm
having some really disturbing dreams
that i don't want to talk about but
they're really making me uncomfortable
and um i may go talk to somebody about
it because they keep showing up and
they're happening every other week every
other week every other week
if you're one of the most common things
i i hear is
hey my wife had a
a dream an intimate dream about an old
boyfriend or
had an intimate dream about somebody at
work or something man
be as hard as it's gonna be be curious
not judgmental
right that doesn't mean she wants to
cheat on you that doesn't mean she's
dreaming about her ex boy i mean she's
literally streaming about her
ex-boyfriend but that doesn't mean that
she's pining away for her ex-boyfriend
right and vice versa it's almost never
about that person
right but sitting on them creates
secrets which create division which
creates
then you find out that you are way far
apart from one another way down
um opposite roads
but man hey i want you to joseph i want
you to try this
and let me know how it goes um man we'll
be
i'll be thinking about this one for a
minute man